now we're now just eight days from the
Fox News Republican primary debate in
Milwaukee so where do things stand oh a
voter in Iowa summed it up this way he
said he likes both Trump and a scientist
and while he has some concerns about
Trump's electability he said The more
indictments that Trump gets the better
his numbers do
well what does that mean Governor Ron
DeSantis joins Me Now to respond from
Tallahassee Governor
um it's good to see you tonight thanks
so much for joining us
um that that does seem to be so far at
least the inescapable truth so so if I'm
you how do I convince the GOP voters
that while these indictments are
obviously political you know lawfare I
guess you could call it that you're
still the one who's most electable how
do you make that argument
well because I think going forward the
question really is is what are we going
to do about all this Laura and what we
need to do is get a president obviously
can beat Biden but that could actually
end the weaponization of federal power
through the doj the FBI so for example
with me as president on day one
Christopher Ray gets sent packing you're
going to see the doj cleared out we are
going to ensure A single standard of
Justice in this country again and and I
can say that with credibility because
I've done that in the State of Florida
we've drained the swamp in here we've
gotten rid of negligent election
supervisors in South Florida we've
removed two different Progressive
prosecutors funded by Soros who were not
enforcing the law so I've shown an
ability to take action and get the job
done and as the president I am going to
do the same thing look our country is in
Decline for a number of different
reasons economic cultural but part of
the reason we're in Decline is because
our constitutional system is totally out
of back we need to get it back in order
I'm the guy that knows how to do but you
got to be disciplined you got to be
focused uh you got to have attention to
detail because the swamp is not going to
give up its power voluntarily
so do you think that if Trump were to
win that he wouldn't fire Rey or
wouldn't try to reform the FBI it seems
like he has a a personal interest in
really doing that at this point no
well he had three years to fire
Christopher Ray and he didn't fire him
and remember I went to the rallies in
2016. Laura you remember him uh lock her
up lock her up about holding Hillary
accountable and then two weeks after the
election he said never mind that I said
that and let her off the hook and so I
think if you look at it I give him
credit even though you know we're
competing uh for the great things he did
do but one of the things he did not do
was drain the swamp I mean the swamp got
worse in his four years and you had
people like Ray you had people in power
who were not getting the job done you
got to take very Swift action and you
got to make it happen
now their GOP strategies I think this
was a piece in the hill that are
predicting on the on the Senate side and
on the house side a turnout disaster
if somehow if Trump doesn't become the
nominee Governor saying that many of his
core supporters who are estimated to
make up 25 to 35 percent of the party
base will take their ball and go home
now we saw this somewhat in Georgia
during those runoff elections Governor
are you concerned about that and how
will you spur turnout if indeed you win
the nomination
well I would also say 2022 in Georgia
you saw Governor Brian Kemp when a
thumping re-election uh better than a
lot of people were predicting you know
Donald Trump opposed him uh throughout
that that election even suggested Stacey
Abrams would be a better governor and
then in Florida you know we won
re-election by a record margin for a
republican over 1.5 million votes you
know Donald Trump attacked me uh three
days before the midterm election and so
I think when you're talking about voters
uh in our party base that may be a
problem if you nominate some Rockefeller
Republican but it's not going to be a
problem if you nominate somebody like me
who has a proven record of delivering on
America First policies and how many
people get elected they over promise and
they under deliver I can say both
credibility I met all the promises I
made to the people Florida in fact I
over delivered on my promises whether it
was holding China accountable illegal
immigration education all these things
we said we do we got done
yeah one of the best things you did
Governor was send those migrants up to
Martha's Vineyard that still goes down
as one of the greatest moments because
it showed the Elites for who they really
are not compassionate they uh they
revolving doored them out of there so
fast so that was one of the best smaller
moments but that would that actually
mattered Governor um Chris Christie you
know he's out there you know sticking
his chest out saying like I'm Number Two
now in New Hampshire you worried about
him
now look I think that uh uh at the end
of the day we're doing what we need to
do on the ground in Iowa New Hampshire
we're going to be back there this
weekend uh and we're going to get the
job done uh I think a lot of these guys
are you know doing this and doing that
you know we're going to be able to get
on the debate stage and we're going to
be able to Hash it out and I think I'll
be able to show that I'm the guy that's
got the vision I'm the guy that can get
the job done electorally and then most
important actually get all this stuff
done because we've been talking about so
many of this all this stuff from illegal
immigration in the Border decades
dealing with China all this stuff now is
the time to do it and if we don't do it
in 2024 you know I don't think we're
going to be able to get the job done in
our lifetime so this is a key election
so we can reverse the decline of this
country and give us a new birth of
freedom
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else